donald trump is officially
declaring war on republicans
yes on i guess what is still considered
his own republican party
donald trump put out a statement
yesterday going after
many republicans but in particular mitch
mcconnell
take a listen to this donald trump
putting out a statement
through the save america pac
which is a pro-trump pac trump can't
tweet now
so he's putting it out through the pack
let's go through it and
and look at just the the uh double speak
that we see here all right let's get
started the republican party can never
again be respected or strong
with political quote leaders like mitch
mcconnell at its helm
mcconnell's dedication to business as
usual status quo policies together with
his lack of political insight wisdom
skill and personality
has rapidly driven him from majority
leader to minority leader and it will
only get worse so
trump here putting the blame of
republicans losing the senate
on everybody but himself this is common
trump does this all the time blame other
people
the reality is that trump's failures
including his failure on kovid are a big
part
of not only why he lost the white house
but why republicans lost the senate so
trump blaming other people
he should be looking at himself trump
going on the democrats and chuck schumer
play mcconnell like a fiddle
they've never had it so good and they
want to keep it that way we know our
america first agenda
is a winner not mcconnell's beltway
first agenda or biden's america
last in 2020 i received the most votes
of any sitting president in history
almost 75 million now remember
he lost by millions of votes the real
story is biden got more votes than
anybody ever
trump goes on every incumbent house
republican won for the first time in
decades
and we flipped 15 seats almost costing
nancy pelosi her job
republicans won majorities and at least
59 of the 98 partisan legislative
chambers
and the democrats failed to flip a
single legislative chamber from red to
blue
and in mitch's senate over the last two
election cycles
i single-handedly saved at least 12
senate seats that's delusions of grander
more than eight in the 2020 cycle alone
and then came the georgia disaster where
we should have won both u.s senate seats
but mcconnell matched the democrat offer
of two thousand dollar stimulus checks
with six hundred dollars
how does that work it became the
democrats principal advertisement and a
big winner for them it was
trump ignores that neither david perdue
nor kelly leffler the two
georgia incumbent republicans who lost
were loudly out there talking about two
thousand dollars
understand that as well so putting it on
mcconnell from another state
when when uh it doesn't really bear any
resemblance to what actually took place
there is very weird
trump then goes on mcconnell then put
himself one of the most unpopular
politicians in the u.s into the
advertisements
many republicans in georgia voted
democrat or just didn't vote
because of their anguish at their inept
governor brian kemp secretary of state
brad raffensberger and the republican
party
for not doing its job on election
integrity during the 2020 presidential
race this appears to be totally wrong
trump is saying the reason georgia
incumbent republicans
purdue and leffler lost is that georgia
republican officials didn't
didn't go with everything trump wanted
to try to steal the election from joe
biden
the truth is many georgia republicans
opted out because they were disgusted
at trump trying to steal the election
and they didn't want to reward leffler
and perdue by voting for them
given their alignment with donald trump
trump continues it was a complete
election disaster in georgia and certain
other
swing states mcconnell did nothing and
will never do what needs to be done in
order to secure a fair and just
electoral system into the future
he doesn't have what it takes never
didn't never will now this is of course
sour grapes
i i think mcconnell's disgusting but
mcconnell
has been an insanely effective operator
for the republican party
holding off on the senate the supreme
court seat that should have been filled
by merrick garland by
with barack obama's selection held it
open for trump to pick somebody
got hundreds of conservative judges
approved like i think mcconnell's
disgusting but to say he's been
ineffective
is wrong and trump this is just now sour
grapes
trump going on my only regret is that
mcconnell begged for my strong support
and endorsement before the great people
of kentucky in the 2020 election
and i gave it to him he went from one
point down to 20 points up and won how
quickly he forgets
without my endorsement mcconnell would
have lost and lost badly
now his numbers are lower than ever
before he is destroying the republican
side of the senate
and in so doing seriously hurting our
country
likewise mcconnell has no credibility on
china
because of his family's substantial
chinese business holdings he does
nothing under this tremendous economic
and military threat
funny how trump didn't care about that
when he was working with mcconnell
and had mcconnell's wife elaine chao as
his secretary of transportation
mitch is a dour sullen and unsmiling
political hack
and if republican senators are going to
stay with him they will not win again
he will never do what needs to be done
or what is right for our country
where necessary and appropriate i will
back primary rivals who espouse making
america great again
and our policy of america first we want
brilliant strong thoughtful and
compassionate leadership
prior to the pandemic we produce the
greatest economy okay blah blah blah
trump goes on with some stuff
that that is just his normal bragging
this is very interesting
first of all um i think that it's
important to
understand that at a big picture level
trump right now still represents the
majority of the republican electorate
64 percent of the republican electorate
willing to leave the party if trump
starts his own party
89 percent of the republican electorate
wants trump to stay significantly
involved in politics
that being said i have argued that a
split in the republican party is good
for the left if the left is ready to
take advantage of it
the risk of course is if it goes
neocon versus q anon right
standard republicans and then the trump
crazies if they split if it's
q anon versus neocon if q anon wins
if it grows and wins it would be really
bad
for the united states and the world
that's the risk
i don't believe that that's likely to
happen
but it remains to be seen as far as
mcconnell goes
you know if trump's going to primary try
to primary republicans
i think that big picture that's also
good for democrats and for the left
i don't think mcconnell really cares
about this mcconnell six years from now
when mitch mcconnell's 84
and he's running maybe for re-election
and trump is 80.
i don't know that this internal uh
challenge or threat from trump is going
to really be that big of a deal but
that's the latest for now in donald
trump appearing to launch
a civil war on his own republican party
very very interesting
and we'll have more coverage of this on
our instagram page you can follow us on
instagram
at david pakman show we'll be back right
after this
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea
of going into a doctor's office right
now and thankfully
there's a practical and affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one-hour
video call with your new doctor you
establish a meaningful relationship with
them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone
or video chat this is not a random
doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or copays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz see which doctor is right for
you
i took their quiz they matched me with a
doctor who specializes in my particular
health needs and situation the doctor
they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk
no commitment to get started just click
the link right underneath this video